[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors à tous les téléspectateurs nouveau
qui nous rejoignent
tania jean luc lemoine y regarde tout ce
qui se passe pendant les pubs et pendant
voilà comment qu'on n'ait pas à
l'antenne on est à l'antenne en fête est
aussi regarde voilà ce qui se passe
quand je suis là que je donne la parole
à quelqu'un quelqu'un peut pas parler en
fait il regarde tout ce que je peux pas
voir vous avez conclu votre explication
nord mais a bloqué des questions de
genre dans la rue tout de suite et ils y
répondent surtout mais je vais essayer
surtout pour je m'appelle maïté j'ai
remarqué que pendant votre rubrique
cyril hanouna dit très souvent que vous
êtes un tabac qu'est ce que ça veut dire
exactement
elle est originaire de tarbes le fait
que vous nous rejoignez nombreux là sur
ces listes on va les quatre tiers de
jean luc lemoine jean luc c'est à toi
c'est pas alors c'est une très bonne
question que vous posez la maïté mais
non je ne suis pas originaire de tarbes
et d'ailleurs les habitants de cette
jolie ville s'appelle les tarbais et pas
les tares bardot dans le langage fleuri
de cyril tarbah veut dire bâtard et
s'ils m'appellent souvent ainsi c'est
parce qu'il aurait de ne pas montrer que
d image valorisante de lui à lui préféré
que j'expose ces moments où pendant la
pub pour passer le temps ils récitent
des poèmes de lamartine omc que ces
moments n'existe pas alors je monte que
j'ai résultats cinéma donner ce petit
nom délicieux et une exclu tmp avoir
réservé à je fais un tarbais par le
soleil me demander pourquoi ce matin
[Applaudissements]
tanoh si les semaines un matin alors
c'est sympa les résultats quand je
rentre à la maison mes enfants son
personnel je m'appelle les papas tarbes
à ça près de moi alors je vais faire des
efforts pour ne montrer que des moments
valorisant et de rendre hommage
merci j'ai fait le trio c'est pour ça
que ce soir je montrerai pas des moments
où vous chantez du maître gims nuit j'ai
bien commencé notre guise oui c'est quoi
votre chanson préférée de maître gims à
j'avoue je ne sais pas je fais que
survenait réussi à une position avec ce
une question à l'invité ce magnifique
texte hudec 82 bon je passerai pas du
maître gims je passerai pas non plus dû
sabrina ah ouais bah oui j'adore le look
est fort de good time en garde les
malades et quand même alors pendant
longtemps on a cru et enfin on a dit que
my way c'est la chanson d'origine
française a pu chanter au monde
finalement vous écoutant semaine après
semaine souvent si ça plutôt bof moi le
culte de jacques brel
je crois que c'est un goal qui a écrit
ça
dr ce soir je passerai pas ce jardinage
j'ai plutôt rendre hommage au créateur
cet homme qui pendant le mois de
septembre a lancé plus de nouvelles
rubriques dans tpm clé le tout les
émissions du paf réunit la petite astuce
d'ailleurs pour vous chez vous quand
après une nouvelle rubrique cindy à ça
on aime ça ça va revenir
on va dire que ça reviendra par exemple
pour donner un peu de crédibilité à
l'émission cyril avait créé les pépites
à tepito as well as d'or c'est un peu
tard mija doris
voilà qui est un peu l'équivalent de
tracks sur arte j'adore dessiner sa
bosse à clignoter en fin d'émission
bon la vérité c'est que ça a dû partir
d'un jeu de mots est à présent réfléchir
au concept mais là où cyril et
sincèrement un génie c'est dans sa
faculté à s'adapter improvisé cas car
quand une actu dramatique vient se
greffer au lancement d'une rubrique
potache et que tu le réalise en plein
direct faut être un sacré équilibristes
pour réussir la transition
ça s'appelle un écart facial
[Applaudissements]
merci vous êtes venus du mexique
les chevrolet carcela mexico en ce
moment où on pense très fort mais c'est
bien je sais pas si avec nous regarde
mais merci merci à vous je sais pas je
tiens à qui nous regardent alors que des
mexicains nous regardent en direct j'ai
déjà un doute mais qu'ils le fassent bus
après un séisme d'autres soucis à gérer
trop dépêchons-nous il ya touche pas à
mon poste c'est qu'après horloge je vois
pépito bond menthe espagnol et
d'ailleurs il est alors mené l'espagne
oui oui très bien ça c'est en reste il
est très créatif
veilleux pas peur des mots c'est un
génie des temps modernes écoutez et
d'ailleurs personne ne comprends qu'ils
ne soient pas encore au musée grévin
deux ans après l annonce de son entrée
en vrai mystère ce premier à se poser la
question de jouer dans l'équipe
chacun avait son explication pourquoi la
voterai pas fini ça fait deux ans qu'ils
sont jugés beaucoup de poils
abon manier bravo à boston ah bon c'est
pas très respectueux c'est rien par
rapport à ce qu'a fait jean michel maire
vous rappelez de votre anniversaire
ouais je veux pas vous montrer la
séquence mais pas vous faire de peine
mais je vous cache pas que cette semaine
je suis un peu en galère d'image alors
je balance tout jean-michel essayer de
vous nuire non le jeu le jour même où on
célébrer votre anniversaire
non vous avez un téléphone sur le
plateau pour le soir des appels de
célébrités oui oui mais voilà ce qui a
servi dans des salades
[Musique]
mais du cirad loi c-19 engagement de
l'odyssée
je suis content
désormais que sauf que sur l'écouteur on
écoute
et
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
à l'époque la pente on lire
je voulais
non
on
[Musique]
la banda est folle la mode à l'époque
noria soprano
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est bien mal de chien
ces résultats mais c'est donc à elle
m'appelait là bas avec voulait faire dé
12 douce a même pas marcher
ramon du christ entrave aujourd'hui
allez passons plutôt des choses
positives comme la nouvelle coiffure de
valérie b diary qui a été l'un des
événements médias de la semaine dernière
en tout cas chez nous
[Musique]
non
bah ouais
bon je crois que gilles à une petite
émotion
en clair il a bandé et là aussi ça me va
très bien valérie réjean côté très serré
mais j'aimerais bien y amener on dirait
dorothée du maroc c'est ça on dirait
double alors de façon ce côté là c'est
le côté sexy des chroniqueurs il y avait
les rives il ya aussi bien sûr maxime
guény incriminé qui n'a pas été recruté
que pour ses compétences journalistiques
et beau temps non s'il est là c'est
parce qu'il a une utilité bien
particulière que j'ai apprise en
écoutant aof
tiens c'est lui même qui a expliqué à
yagg est en quoi il était important dans
l'équipe non
[Musique]
j'ai toujours été factuel dans cette
émission je le resterai
voilà un chapeau qui en fou or voilà
maxime est utile car nous nous sommes
des vieux pull en grosses sommes alors
tant qu'il est là profitons-en un petit
vent de fraîcheur spécialement pour vous
[Musique]
j'ai beau cadeau un cadeau virtuel si je
vous dit rov si je vous dis boba
[Musique]
dutoit
c'est à la wii
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les standards des juniors je pense qu
amateurs de mac singh un petit vieux qui
crient au secours sans témoin de la c3
maxime beaucoup plus 1,2 qu'on le croit
à l'antenne il s'en vend des grandes
phrases définitives et en off il fait
profil bas et devant des conseils ses
camarades les plus expérimentés
là par exemple se demander quelle était
la bonne taille pour faire de la
télévision bon là que je fais déjà
étrange si si en plus ils apposent à
jean michel maire n'est pas bien c'est
comme ça
il
[Musique]
comme la tribune
ça
[Musique]
il a la voix mais qu'est ce qui lui
passe balade les rien à voir tu as bien
chez nous quand même non non si si
bonnes réponses
68 kg à mazicou 18 minutes ils vont
plutôt me tienne oui oui beaucoup
c'est vrai oui on s'est réparti oui
attention on va écouter je ne sais pas
ils sont tous beaux j'avais plutôt bien
habillés sur kelly mais enfin bon si
vous êtes très jolie expression leur
éthique comment je vous aime beaucoup
merci non mais c'est jean luc et je suis
moi je suis ravi des mollahs gravier
aussi d'être sur le plateau christophe
beaugrand
je suis impartial à la paix mais nous
[Musique]
nous le disent et une dernière fois du
mal à cacher sa pensée sur l'échelle
c'est quand même du très haut niveau et
une façons les conversations entre
maxime et jean-michel sont souvent
surréalistes est ce que vous aimez les
mystères cyril oui j'aime bien aller je
parle pas des idées sert qu'on a dans
les restaurants japonais des idées vrai
mystère mais aussi les énigmes et jamais
résolu les choses qu'on ne devrait pas
savoir oui j'aime bien alors je vous
propose une nouvelle rubrique non no
rick d'investigation j'adore ça m'a aidé
aussi secret de tpm paix en mai car ici
on est pas qu une bande de rigolos
on sait aussi des choses stupéfiantes on
peut pas révéler l'antenne car c'est car
les gens sont pas prêts simplement
enfin on sait soir je vais vous parler
de mickey oui oui mickey la petite
souris dont vous respecter par quoi si
vous pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi
mickey oui mais quel jeu vous dire mes
clés pour vous savez pour la bâti un
empire avec cap doit pas j'ai appris
quelque chose sur votre idole quoi
quelque chose d'hallucinant que personne
ne savait c'est le premier numéro des
dossiers secrets de tpm p
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'info ce temps une souris qui a peur
d'une chose c'est normal
[Applaudissements]
ana moura souza contente d'être là en
rap us est ravi d'être sur un bateau que
je serai mâchoire édentée soirée de nous
en parler
[Rires]
je reviendrai les égouts
ah oui voilà figure on est dans les eaux
grand mystère n'est aussi lehning des
fiches éventail oui je sais pas si vous
avez remarqué mais en fonction de qui
est assis à côté d'elle
j'ai un dîner valérie se servent de leur
fiche pour avoir du vent ouais on
pensait que c'était la chaleur sur le
plateau non malheureusement non non
[Musique]
ici on
je
mais le jeu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
samatan et christophe il va courir
ok c'est une très belle transition pour
le top gênante population des petits
moments étranges et un glaçage de tpm
avant qu'on lance vous voulez une petite
info mais je me demande où bethania
demain donc existait déjà été pas
d'antenne baer qui s'appelle le meilleur
inventeur qui avait déjà été un four
sanaa c'est cyclique
c'est cyclique air extrait je me suis
vite et
[Musique]
fort
m
[Musique]
la fièvre du samedi soir
elle cartonne et elle met beaucoup
d'entrain à tout ce qu'elle fait c'est
vrai la caisse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d
[Musique]
et les souches d'arbres
c
tu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]